foreign
[Music]
for Barbie Margot Robbie insists on
using her own body in close-ups the
actress revealed this in a new interview
with Fandango it was all about the start
of the Barbie trailer the feet of the
famous character get out of her pink
heels and just stay in the same
stretched position Margot Robbie
confirmed that these are indeed her feet
a bit of tape for the Footwear a pole to
hold on to and about eight attempts done
was the funny effect the well-known
Harley Quinn actress emphasized that in
her movies she usually does these
so-called inserts herself that is
detailed shots of hands feet and so on
can't stand seeing the finished film and
knowing that the body parts shown don't
actually belong to her Robbie is thus
rather an exception in Hollywood
typically so-called body doubles are
used for scenes in which the faces of
high-paid stars cannot be seen the new
Barbie movie with Margot Robbie and Ryan
Gosling is currently a big talking point
in Hollywood the entire project is
creating a real Barbie boom in Malibu
you will soon even have the chance to
spend the night in Barbie's dream house
all in pink of course after initial
doubts director Greta gerwig's film
Project has managed to convince a
growing number of movie fans to check
out the film at least since the first
trailers were released in addition to
the ironic yet affectionate treatment of
the cult figure the simultaneous
theatrical release with Christopher
Nolan's Oppenheimer on July 21 2023 is a
particular cause for amusement we can't
wait to see whether the premature praise
is Justified
[Music]
thank you